[Music]
tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates the
other epstein new revelations about the
leader of a church claiming 5 million
members under indictment and behind bars
in California charged with recruiting
underaged girls from his congregation
for depraved sex acts things he's not
only an apostille but he thinks he's
living Christ on this earth well he was
behind bars and over-the-top wedding for
his daughter as former church members
come forward to allege he has diverted
Church money for his family's privileged
life because I know how hard the church
members try to give as much as they can
and now
a growing movement of former church
members coming together on social media
to reveal what goes on behind the scenes
is it a church or is it a cult
threatening those who would try to leave
so as far as they're concerned I'm 6
feet underground already because I have
gone against the apostle of Jesus Christ
on this earth plus the wave of domestic
terror attacks a former FBI agent is
here to tell us what it will take to
stop the American carnage and our
shoutout the investigative reporter in
Alaska who found dozens of convicted
felons hired as police officers still on
job do you think it affects your ability
to be a police officer here at all not
really from the law and crime Network
studios in New York City's Herald Square
this is Brian Ross investigates and good
evening and welcome tonight the other
Epstein a wealthy powerful man accused
of sex trafficking with underaged girls
and now awaiting trial in a jail cell in
Los Angeles this accused sexual predator
is a man of the cloth the leader of a
church that claims millions of members
in the United States and around the
world his name is Mason Joaquin Garcia
and his arrest has created turmoil among
his followers creating heartbreak and
tearing families apart
Raquel Guerra
was 14 years old and living in Texas
when she was told by her church that she
had to marry her boyfriend because they
had had sex
they had fornicated her pastor told her
I kind of felt like there wasn't really
a choice because you're kind of scared
because you're kind of scared of
actually going to hell because they
really really put that in your head and
she says it became a marriage marked by
physical abuse and heartbreak with the
church indifferent to her plight maybe
it's something that I'm doing to pray to
God maybe to change my ways that maybe
I'm provoking this in some way her
church is known as the light of the
world church claiming to have 5 million
members around the world with more than
a million members in the United States
with churches in every one of the 50
states but California authorities say
it's supposed strict moral standards
don't seem to be followed by the leader
of the church the man who calls himself
the apostle of Jesus the san joaquin
garcia accused of the very same sort of
crimes that Jeffrey Epstein faced she is
photograph there and two of his
co-defendants in a major sex trafficking
and sex abuse case joaquin garcia is now
under indictment behind bars in los
angeles awaiting trial on char
that he and his followers recruited
teenage girls for a series of depraved
sex acts the type of crimes that belong
nowhere in our society from human
trafficking production of child
pornography oral copulation rape
statutory rape child molestation
extortion conspiracy and more and now
former members of the church have begun
to organize using social media including
this site on reddit a public effort to
expose what they say is the corrupt
hypocritical and immoral leadership of
Joaquin Garcia and his worldwide church
he's demented he he's not right in the
head
he thinks he's not only an apostle but
he thinks he's the Living Christ on this
earth when he speaks to his congregation
he literally when he walks through his
walkway
he says you have not received me as only
as an apostle of Christ you have
received me as Jesus Christ himself this
man who we will call Jose says he became
disgusted with the church as he realized
the sexual depravity of joaquin garcia
he says the church is more like a cult
that an actual religion designed to
benefit joaquin garcia and his family
while king Garcia's grandfather founded
the church it was passed on to his son
and then to the current leader we're
taught that the you're supposed to love
the apostille more than your mom more
than your dad more than your wife more
than your husband more than your kids
more than anybody on this earth because
they compared him with the power of God
the voice of God he in flesh here on
earth and you cannot go to the Father or
to the son without going through him
first
so they teach you have believed in God
in vain you have believed in Jesus
Christ in vain if you don't believe in
the apostille on this earth the church
spends huge sums on its apostle with
elaborate birthday party celebrations
this church in Oregon
to the big public happy birthday video
the church has built a private zoo and
rents for the Apostle in Texas and even
as he was behind bars in California his
daughter was married in an over-the-top
wedding in California to the dismay of
many former members aggravates me
because I know how hard the church
members try to give as much as they can
they go without to be blessed to give
such a big offering and them to do
things of this nature with their
hard-earned money the church insist is
leader the Apostle is innocent of any
wrongdoing and it has told its followers
to pray for joaquin garcia to be found
not guilty church leaders have also told
members to shun to ignore those who
speak out against it
what song what up little man even if it
were your brother your father their word
eat away like Angry Men cos it is very
dangerous to speak with those be
believed also bloody car kinases
personas the way works in the church is
if you're not with them you're against
them the way it works that what they
preach is if you are deviating from the
path of the Lord you're you're from the
devil now the devil has gotten you the
devil has done everything he could with
you so your conversations you put you're
pretty much meaningless and Jose says
when he appeared on the spanish-language
television network Univision this month
his family told him he was essentially
dead to them right now I'm actually a
disgrace right now I am no longer a son
right now I don't I no longer exist
right now I'm actually pretty much a bum
on the streets I'm sixty underground
already because I have gone against the
apostle of Jesus Christ on this earth
Raquel Guerra says she had to leave the
urghhh once she sought a divorce for her
husband causing strains with her family
I mean we do talk of course but I really
don't have a really close relationship
with my family and especially probably
after this I we're gonna be surprised if
I'm disowned because you're talking with
us right now yes that would be seen as a
sin oh it's worse than a sin it's going
against the man of God you're it's
beyond a sin and void human oh sorry
yeah and so why are you doing it because
I'm tired of seeing my family just
deceived they really they really don't
see it as much as you try and tell them
show them facts they they refuse to even
consider that this could be a cult in a
court filing this week lawyers for
Joaquin Garcia claimed he was framed set
up by women who were in love with him
and sought to make money by extorting
him with what they called false claims
the court papers name one woman who the
lawyers say is part of a conspiracy
against the church leader the lawyers
declined to appear on our program
tonight but say they will come on next
week we hope they do as this story seems
to be far far from over
next a former top FBI profiler on the
recent wave of mass shootings by young
white American males how to stop the
troubling growth of domestic terrorism
when we come back
turning now to the wave of domestic
terror attacks in this country and there
really is no other way to describe this
from El Paso to Dayton in so many other
places this summer stores schools
churches synagogues all targeted the FBI
put together a path for effort in the
wake of 9/11 to go after attackers
aligned with foreign terror groups but
what about those aligned with or
sympathizing with domestic ultra
nationalistic groups to answer that
question we are joined by former FBI
agent and profiler Andrew Rangel and
Andrew I'll start by asking you what can
be done to stop them with the current
laws well someone suggested that the
laws are not strong enough and there
needs to be a domestic terrorist act a
violation that specifically targets
domestic terrorism including the FBI
agents Association I would make the
argument that we've worked domestic
terrorist cases going back to the 1920s
on and these cases have been made on a
number of different violations so while
there may not be a specific federal
statute that says that this is a
terrorist event in a domestic terrorist
event there are a number of cases for
example in the Pittsburgh shooting
Bowers Robert Bowers was charged in 29
federal counts but I think there can be
a lot done to prevent these these cases
from occurring with better prevention
programs for these types of cases better
reporting and we're seeing that just in
the wake of the shootings in Mississippi
in Texas in Ohio and California there
have been 28 arrests in the month of
August of individuals who have made
threats either through social media or
directly to people that they know well
Andrew do you think these cases are
getting the same attention from
Washington from the FBI headquarters and
from the White House has the
international terror cases
I really do Brian I think that what
you're seeing in the last several weeks
as a reaction to those shootings I just
mentioned and you see the same thing
happened with the Ameri Thrax case that
came right after 9/11 I was I was a
headquarters supervisor at the time in
the weapons of mass destruction division
of the unit and we had about 400 hoaxes
anthrax hoaxes before the marathon skate
but
after that actual terrorist then anyone
that was making a hoax was arrested and
you saw the scene uptick in
international investigations
proactive ones after 9/11 see it's
natural that you're going to see those
types of proactive investigations being
ramped up in the bureau throughout the
United States and that's what we're
seeing the 28 arrests and Andrew a
question for you from our control room
from executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda what's your question what's the
fine line between trying to profile
trying to predict who might do this kind
of terrible act and the civil rights of
citizens where do you where do you draw
that line Rhonda that's an excellent
question and at the heart of the issue
of whether or not to have a domestic
terror statute those on the civil
liberty side that social justice side
says if we have that type of statute
that the bureau might be tempted to
cross that line and look at people's
ideology and their way of thinking
director Ray said the FBI doesn't go
after groups because of the way they
think or their philosophy ideology the
FBI goes after their criminal behaviors
and all you have to do is look at the
statute the definition of terrorism and
the very first sentence says unlawful
violence against people or property so I
think that there is some things that can
be done for example if you hear someone
using inappropriate communications
they're making specific threats online
or in person those are red flags and
these red flag operations will allow the
police to get left of the boom and
that's really where we want to be we
want to be responsive before there is a
crime committed so the FBI local and
state police and these task forces that
are looking at these issues they want to
be left of the boom the local population
can be a big help to that end and when
you say left of the boom what do you
really mean well if you look at a
timeline of events Brian you know we
read left to right so if you look at the
timeline as the event the critical
incident or terrorist attack that's the
boom law enforcement wants to be left on
that timeline what we'd like to do is
the three P's so we want prevention we
want prediction
and at the last resort we want to have a
prepared response so the public can
really help by being the eyes and the
ears in the community and where these
individuals are going from an expressed
belief to a stated behavior they're
doing preparatory work they're going out
and develop being hit lists they're
going online and expressing violent
intentions those are the red flags it
should be brought up to local state or
federal law enforcement so that they can
get in that the stream of consciousness
of that offender and determine whether
their seriousness in terms of this these
overt statements and actions and then
determine whether or not they need to
neutralize that individual by an arrest
or a disruption before there's a boom
right that's right last week there were
three cases where loved ones former
girlfriends came forward and said he's
talking about killing people at a
synagogue or a community center that's
the kind of information you can use but
if someone buys a lots of guns that's
not in itself illegal no and that's why
there's no profile for these types of
events Brian I think that it's dangerous
to talk about profiling behaviors
because there isn't one specific type of
individual and when you look at
terrorism specifically this the
definition says it has to be in
furtherance of political or social
objectives so if you have someone who's
mentally or emotionally unstable and
they go into a tower and start shooting
people a mass shooting then if they're
doing that because of mental illness or
because of a personal revenge of
grievance then it's not terrorism and
here we get a lot of confusion as to
what is a terrorist case and what's a
hate crime and what's just you know a
crazy person going in and shooting a
bunch of people good point
former FBI agent Andrew Rangel thank you
so much for joining us excellent
insights up next our shoutout for the
Alaska reporter who first discovered
convicted felons for being hired as
police officers in some of the state's
remote villages dozens of them it turns
out a we come back
and our shutout tonight is an encore for
one of the few investigative reporters
working in Alaska the 49th state a
reporter who we first recognized for
revealing how convicted felons were able
to get jobs as police officers in some
of the state's remote villages but over
the summer he stayed on the story like a
good reporter with some even more
alarming findings that that led powerful
people on Washington to finally take
notice my name is Kyle Hopkins I'm a
reporter and editor for the Anchorage
Daily News in Anchorage Alaska a lot of
the stories that we want to cover and a
lot of the best stories are in these are
plum villages that are hard hard for us
to get to there are all these small
communities with all these small
governments and they work in the shadows
they just do they do what they like
because there's there's no paying
attention because their communities just
are not large enough to support a local
journalist I found that again and again
you would see someone who had been
accused of domestic violence or you know
rape or homicide and you would also find
that that person had at what point and
sometimes still was serving as a police
officer as Hopkins discovered when he
travelled to this village above the
Arctic Circle the village of Selawik
population 850 on November night three
years ago someone gave alcohol to 16
year old Lois Cleveland and then raped
her she died that night and while the
medical examiner called it undetermined
reasons you know they when when Glasgow
State Troopers investigated they found
that she had handcuff marks on her
wrists and the state police soon
determined that the village police
officer who reported the crime Brent
Norton was in fact the one who committed
the crime in an interview recorded by
state police
Norton admitted he had given her liquor
and had sex with her while she was
unconscious
it was not his first crime Hopkins
discovered you know a simple background
check show that he already had been
convicted of bootlegging and he was on
probation for giving alcohol to another
underage girl so you know was had been
you know gone through the criminal
justice system was accused of and found
to be guilty of a crime and was still on
the job used his used his City paycheck
to buy alcohol that they then gave this
girl he raped her
the young victim's mother was distraught
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and then Hopkins set out in the state
capital to ask the officials in charge
if there were other police officers like
Norton convicted of serious crimes but
still on the job and the response from
the spread was worried body you know and
their job is to keep track of the stuff
was you'll be have no idea they just
they didn't know they said no one knew
so that led to a full-fledged effort by
Hopkins and the Anchorage Daily News to
find out more with a new report just
last month which found dozens of police
officers with criminal records including
Hopkins reported this registered sex
offender Nimr on Mike who was hired as a
police officer even after serving six
years behind bars on charges including
assault domestic violence vehicle theft
groping a woman hindering prosecution
reckless driving drunken driving and
Chokey a woman unconscious in an
attempted sexual assault he was hired by
the city of Stebbins on the same day he
applied according to Hopkins another
police officer told Hopkins his criminal
record would not keep him from
in the law record do you think it
affects your ability to be a police
officer here at all no and earlier this
year new Attorney General William bar
came to Alaska and declared a law
enforcement emergency someone asked me
like why why are you here why did you
pick Alaska it's because to me my job is
to go where the need is greatest and I
think the need is greatest here these
are people that are just asking for the
basic physical security and it's not
much to ask like it's the story that I
had been missing and had been right for
my face for years and we got them
finally we just finally mean to address
this that's that's really how it felt
was like you know we should have done
this years ago but let's get this done
and just tell people what's going on and
he has he is the recipient this year of
a grant from the nonprofit pro-public
to continue his reporting as a kind of
one-man wrecking ball against apathy and
corruption I appreciate you know putting
a spotlight on local reporting it's a
lonely job nobody wants it out here so
it's nice to talk to somebody and good
to talk to you so a second and
well-deserved shout out for Kyle Hopkins
and the Anchorage Daily News and for the
nonprofit news group ProPublica which
has helped to support Hoffman's work as
part of a 20 member local news network
around the u.s. filling a very large
void in the world of journalism well
that's our program for tonight thanks
for joining us we'll see you back here
next week good night